we've now been testing and comparing
Apple's M3 family of MacBook Pros for 1
month making many discoveries along the
way and I think I've finally figured out
whether it's worth spending the extra
cash for the $2,000 M3 Pro MacBook Pro
over the $1600 base M3 model because
initially we thought this was a killer
value but after some of the tests I'm
about to show you in this video our
conclusion has completely changed but
before I get into the performance
numbers and our multitasking stress test
results I want to show you guys all of
the major differences the bonus perk
with the more expensive M3 pro model is
that you get to choose the space black
color which I personally love but other
than that the designs are basically
identical on the outside including
having the same 14-in display with the
same feature set like 120 Herz promotion
mini LED Tech and 600 nits of standard
brightness that goes up to 6 1 1600 for
HDR content the $1600 model is of course
limited to the M3 chip which actually
gives it a higher rated battery life of
15 hours of web browsing compared to 12
and the only other noticeable difference
is the fact that it has one less
Thunderbolt Port than the M3 pro model
which has the additional port on the
right side which is very convenient to
have the cameras are the same the
speakers are the same the microphones
the Wi-Fi and bluetooth specs so the
only thing left to discuss is what's on
the inside the chip and the performance
differences first of all the M3 only has
a single fan compared to dual fans on
the M3 Pro and that actually does have
an impact on fan noise with the more
expensive M3 pro model running quieter
throughout a lot of the performance
tests that we ran also the M3 model
seemingly only has two nand storage
chips on the inside which led to a
significant difference in SSD transfer
speeds even though they both come with
the same 512 gigs of storage so right
off the bat there are already a bunch of
advantages that you get by choosing the
$2,000 model and with that said let's
jump into the performance numbers the
most important difference is the fact
that the base M3 model only comes with 8
GB of RAM which as you'll see in a
moment leads to disappointing
performance compared to 18 GB on the M3
pro model which also comes with an
additional three CPU cores and four
extra GPU course so let's jump right
into CPU performance starting with
geekbench 6 and in the single core test
they both have the same performance as
expected but in multicore the M3 Pro is
15% faster which is actually a bit
underwhelming since you're paying 25%
more cash we then tested web design
performance in figma using a project
from 500 designs one of the best Design
Studios based out of California and the
M3 pro model finished about 15 seconds
faster which honestly isn't a big deal
at all so just looking at these two
simple benchmarks it doesn't really seem
worth it but watch what happens when we
get into the real world CPU rendering
test in the new cinnamin
2024 10minute stress test now with
either of them and especially the 14-in
MacBook Pro the best way to boost your
multitasking workflow is with the gemino
Dual stacked monitor from our sponsor
mobile pixels which is a game Cher for
multitasking workflow allowing me to
drag and drop files and clips from the
top display right into my video editing
app on the bottom all while taking
screenshots from my video on my MacBook
saving me time and money and it's all
stacked onto this compact base which
saves death space and comes with a bunch
of extra ports so check out the Gino's
dual stack monitor using the link below
the M3 Pro scored 35% higher in cinam
2024 likely because the B M3 was
throttling with that single fan not able
to sustain the performance so I went
ahead and got into another real world
CPU test which is music production in
logic pro and here the M3 pro model was
able to run 22% more tracks without
overloading which is quite impressive
then I got into xcode programming which
has been rebuilt from the ground up for
xcode 15 and here the regular M3 model
took
27.5% longer to finish the test so it's
already looking quite worth it to invest
the extra 400 bucks into the M3 Pro but
wait it gets even better when we start
looking at GPU performance so starting
off with geekbench 6's metal test we're
looking at a huge gain of 44 .5%
graphics performance with the M3 Pro
which is a huge deal for 25% more cash
but it got even better when we tested
gaming performance using 3D Marks
Wildlife extreme Benchmark where the M3
Pro now gave us a massive 50% more FPS
which basically proves that anyone that
wants to do a bit of gaming should
absolutely buy the MV Pro but then I got
into testing the new cinebench 2024 GPU
rendering test and here the Bas M3
MacBook Pro couldn't even run the test
because the app itself thinks that 8
gigs of RAM isn't enough which is a bit
sad so I had to test the 16 GB Ram M3
model and here the M3 Pro was an
astounding 64% faster than the M3 chip
which is just crazy now one of the
coolest new additions this year is Ray
tracing so I tested blender 3D rendering
which now fully supports it and in the
party tug Cycles Render the M3 Pro chip
model was literally over twice as fast
which was
mindblowing so anybody doing 3D
rendering work absolutely must buy the
M3 Pro if you want to save time so then
I started testing photo editing
performance in Lightroom classic
exporting 50 42 megapixel Raw photos and
the M3 Pro was once again over twice as
fast showing such a big Advantage now
that we're getting into realworld tasks
that people actually do on a day-to-day
basis but the most surprising part of
all is that I also tested the 16 GB Ram
model of the M3 MacBook Pro and that one
actually finished in 1 minute and 6
seconds significantly faster than the 8
gbyte model so that small amount of ram
was killing the performance but it got
even worse when we ran the same test
with just five web tabs open to simulate
a very light multitasking workload which
honestly most people have at least five
tabs open most of the time and the 8 gig
model got even slower to 2 minutes so we
Ed the stakes even more and opened up 10
web tabs with a variety of different
pages open and guess what it slowed down
massively to 5 minutes and 16 seconds
which is just ridiculous which shows
that 8 GB of RAM is not enough for
running performance tasks while
multitasking but wait it gets even worse
because we tested video editing in the
new 10.7 version of Final Cup Pro and
while our 5K hvc export test finished at
the same time because both models are
limited by the encoders we ran our
craziest 8K Canon raw R5 export and once
again the M3 Pro finished over twice as
fast as the 8 GB M3 model and just by
upgrading the Ram from 8 gigs to 16 on
the M3 we saved over 5 minutes on the
export time and keep in mind that this
test didn't even include any web browser
tabs open at all so it would have been
even slower while multitasking so the
obvious answer is that anybody who cares
about performance should definitely
upgrade to 16 GB of RAM but then the
problem is that we're now at $1,800
total just 200 bucks shy of the M3 pro
model actually no the M3 Pro is
currently on sale on Amazon brand new
for
$150 off for a total of
$1850 which is a steal of a deal and
while the M3 model is also on sale for
100 bucks off right now so it's just
1,500 it's unfortunately the 8 GB Ram
model and you can't even configure it up
to 16 gigs of RAM on Amazon so you're
stuck paying full price from the Apple
store and then you've got to remember
the other differences like the extra
Thunderbolt port and the Dual fans for
quieter operation so if you factor all
of the differences I am now 100% sure
that everybody who cares about
performance at all should be buying the
M3 pro model for $1850 on Amazon and
I'll leave a link to that sale down
below so hopefully you enjoyed this one
month testing comparison and if you did
go ahead and subscribe above and check
out how the base M3 pro model compares
to the upgraded chip version right over
there thanks for watching and we'll see
you in the next
[Music]
video